the jurogan experience yeah the reason
why i brought that up is because
camaro's definitely talking about he
just wants a big money fights now yeah
so i get that well he's probably
like a year away from a knee replacement
yeah right if you watched him walk
downstairs like that he's i know michael
bisping had both his knees replaced once
he retired
yeah i mean same [ __ ]
and his eye well his eye is not replaced
but it's fake yeah he has a well he has
like a contact that he puts in that
makes it look yeah it looks good yeah
but i've seen him put him pop it out
too it's a carnival yeah i mean
yeah so i mean my point was
if camaro starts i was wondering if he's
thinking about like the money so you you
you know that what's the saying is the
wolf climbing the hill is always hungry
than the wolf on top of the hill
something like that so i mean you know
colby's still trying to get up there
camaro's been up there do you lose that
hunger a little bit
i don't think so
i don't think so not with that guy i
think at the championship level like the
true champions and i think camaro is
like a champion of champions i think i
think he's
in this all-time great category like
like let's imagine this fight is not
taking place right now and you're not
comparing him with colby you just look
at what he's done so far and his skill
level i think he got a real argument
that he is right now the best
pound-for-pound fighter in the sport if
you look at what his accomplishments are
one loss ever in his entire mixed
martial arts career has run through
everyone in his division
including winning the title over a
dominant tyron woodley five round route
just destroyed him his beat beat him
pillar to post every round
and then you look at his fights with um
maz vidal you look at his fight with
colby look at this fight with gilbert
burns gilbert is a dangerous man and he
put him away and gilbert heard him he
hurt him in the first round camaro
recovered and smashed him knocked out
mozvidal with one punch in this in the
second fight
he's a real argument that he's the best
guy in the sport
yeah but if you wanted to see him
challenged
you would want a guy who's got killer
wrestling that's colby amazing gas tank
that's colby unstoppable mentality
that's colby and a guy who's been in
there with him and knows what
adjustments to make right you know i
think
you know when mozville took that first
fight he took the first fight on short
notice yeah and six days he had some
good moments in the fight but ultimately
he fell prey to usman's conditioning you
know and and usually said the reason why
he was willing to fight me then was
because he had a built-in excuse yeah i
saw him which is interesting because
that would [ __ ] with a man's head yeah
you call him a journeyman and you know
that [ __ ] with a guy's head like the
difference in the accomplishments of the
two are very different like mozvidal
obviously has that giant ben askr
knockout and he beat up nate diaz in
that fight and hospital is a bad
[ __ ] and a very clever fighter
he's one of my favorite guys to watch
fight because he's so intelligent but
uzman just demolished him
demolished him that's what separates
like very good fighters from all-time
greats and he had a full camp that time
yeah maz vidal did
didn't help now he's actually helped him
less like he was better but i think
usman's better than he was before i
think he's he continues to get better
and he's training with trevor whitman
like he he moved camps you know he used
to be down in south florida and then he
made his way yeah he was
it was originally the black zillions it
was stanford's but he's now with trevor
whitman who's a like a real striking
genius
you know trevor whitman is a brilliant
guy yeah
i was i've always loved what he's done i
mean because with gait she and with rose
yeah like man he's got three fighters in
the main card that's pretty crazy that
shows you how good trevor whitman is
yeah he also makes the best gloves in
the business yeah his gloves are [ __ ]
fantastic yeah you've been lobbying for
this oh my god you're so good at those
well not just his glo his boxing gloves
i i use his gloves to hit the bag he
makes the best shin pads he makes the
best equipment like it's crazy that you
got a coach
who is also designing equipment and he
was explaining to me that the foam that
they use the foam that most people use
is not the best foam it's like the best
cost effective phone
so he uses like the best top of the food
chain
space age technology foam and like you
really feel the difference when you like
hit things with his gloves like it's
better protection for your hands no
yeah i know i've i've seen i've watched
some stuff on him and
uh i'm a fan he's a wizard i'm a fun guy
too and they have a good he has a good
relationship a good rapport with his uh
his students you know which is
so important because he's a he's a good
guy to get along with you know he's a
fun guy
and so like watching him coach these
people and seeing like three
top flight fighters on the same card
it's incredible i'm i'm pretty intrigued
too with the coaching changes for oozman
and colby they both changed cams yeah so
what happened with kobe you're friends
with kobe he what was uh what led him to
switch camps because he was with att
forever it seemed like i mean i don't
know it seemed like there's a bunch of
drama down there you know because i
think poirier's down there and and uh
i don't know it seems like he's he said
that or for what i'm seeing on
interviews um
you know there's drama going into train
and
he just wanted to get away from that do
you want to deal with it yeah and it's a
that's a big organization down there
basically it's a lot of fighters and so
then he switched to this i think it's
mma masters and you know small gym they
give him the full attention so yeah
i don't know well he brings the drama he
shouldn't be shocked
i mean who the [ __ ] causes more drama
than colby
i know yeah still good stuff that's how
he's so popular it's it's both things
right which is rare like he has
incredible skill level he's as tough as
they come
and
he talks a lot of [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's good and most people don't
know that he got forced into talking
[ __ ] like the ufc was about to cut him
they didn't like his style they told him
yeah and so then he fought damien mai in
brazil and then called him a bunch of
filthy animals and you know and said a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] this is a dump yeah
yeah they went crazy they took exception
to that he went pro wrestling heel yeah
and it changed it worked it changed the
trajectory of his career what people
don't know about colby what you know
about colby is when you're with him in
person
super nice guy oh he's actually
soft-spoken he's a great guy he's he's
had dinner at the house we had elk and
uh just polite soft-spoken
my wife and daughter everybody's there
just being as nice as can be he's a
gentleman that's that's who he is that's
the real guy yeah for sure this other
thing is like a character that he does
which is so fascinating
it works i mean
i watched to interview him and dc just
did just a couple days ago and uh and i
mean dc gave him every opportunity he's
like do you ever get tired do you ever
sit at home and say i would you know
could could give it a rest and just be
and he's just like
no
he's like
i'm always he's something like he's
always on then he's like you know dc
said do you respect uzman you know i'm
like as a fighter he's like no
so he wouldn't even
i mean he's sticking to the script yeah
well he's got that pro wrestling heel
character down and if he ever decides to
leave the ufc and go to pro wrestling he
would have a giant career in pro
wrestling if he wanted to probably oh my
god if he if he decided if he fought you
know let's say you know whatever happens
with his career but like five years from
now if he decides to go to pro wrestling
my god will that guy have a [ __ ]
career over there yeah he's talked so
much [ __ ] oh i know it's good i can't
wait yeah it's gonna be an amazing fight
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify